well from from what like i'm hearing
right now you know like i'd say like the
closest comparison i think of in the
west is you know people maybe pay for
like us like an experience if they have
like a really weird fetish or something
right and it seems like in japan this is
just like the social fetish in a way
where it's just they're paying for like
a certain experience that you know that
maybe maybe they can't you know stay out
in normal life it was cool on the screen
why are you laughing why are you
laughing it's really true though you
know
what's so funny about
i'm just it
facts right he just realized that he
worked for a social fetish
i think that's what he realized i
realized that i'm rubbing my own fetish
too at the same time you know yeah yeah
it's an ego stroke right it's not like i
don't enjoy it you know no it's yeah bro
is there a bigger ego stroke than being
paid to like have people talk like yeah
yeah people pamper you
exactly but like my general impression
of it when i left i was like
you know because you have all this
[ __ ] anime all around host club and
you hear about host clubs oh it's so
cool you know you think this is kind of
like cool kind of like
you know when i left i was like [ __ ]
this is depressing as [ __ ] yeah i'd say
like
most of the
clients there
seemed like depressed right it was like
it was it was hot the hosts
some of the hosts and some of the girls
where the [ __ ] did you go to man they
just like i just felt like they they
would just describe it like they had
like nothing else to do like it was i i
don't know for me
oh god i'm sure for some girls though
that is the case right and that's and i
think that's why they go to host clubs
is because that's the only place where
as you said like they've been [ __ ] on
the entire day yeah they just want
someone to make them feel good right you
have this [ __ ] club they gotta deal
with me putting the camera in their
[ __ ] face i felt so bad
you've been awkward as [ __ ] jesus christ
maybe they're only depressed in front of
the camera
that might have been here
like cool the one time i get privacy
this dude is a camera you disagree with
that or you think it was it's all like
fun no i i agree with you bro
not cause you know one thing that i have
to always remember is you know the
customers that i attract versus the
average joe is right
yeah right i guess you're
you're
you're not going you're not attracting
the same types of people that i was
being introduced to i think none of my
customers are miserable [ __ ] well though
i i met one person in that video who
could speak english and she was super
chill she was really cool yeah really
really nice they were miserable because
they couldn't talk to you yeah
but i just saw how they interacted
because i was i was getting like live
translations in my ear the whole time
and i was like watching it and it was
like
i was like
what was like the stuff they were
talking about was depressing or it was
just kind of how like or just the
atmosphere the atmosphere i don't you
know it was don't get me wrong that
seemed like the club was going well but
like sometimes they would say things and
i was like jesus christ
you know they would say something that
was like you know they were trying to
like i don't know they were trying to go
for something and the guy was like
oh [ __ ] like watching car crashes or
something yeah yeah it's just like oh my
god it's like trying not to cringe
compilations yeah yeah
it was you know
it's weird it is a weird world
it's strange what's like some of the
weirdest [ __ ] you've seen
i'm sure you've got stories i'll be
asked for that
then that you're allowed to tell
obviously
who don't get ready
family friendly story is
now no no no no no no no i mean i mean
if look
people think yeah when people think
crazy host stories they're going to
think of some crazy we're not on [ __ ]
bbc yeah yeah but also you have to think
about the current people who employ me
as well you know they might
yeah okay some generic things you've
seen in the host industry or some dodgy
things that go under the host industry
yeah wow or maybe something you
personally experienced that you thought
was a bit um dodgy
well i guess um this is an interesting
one so the way they do their
shimekoka
in japanese so this is the way you
actually boost your numbers within the
industry right um so shimei is as i
mentioned in the beginning of the
episode this is when you have people
choose you as their daddy the more
people choose after your daddy your your
rank gets higher yeah billboard so
people notice you more yeah so one way
to do that is go to other clubs like
kabakura like female oriented clubs as
your host boys yeah and then
stuff exactly and give them your you
know vote and then tell them this is
where i work at
give them your phones you got to come
here and vote for me and they're like
all right sure and then they come vote
for you it's like presidential campaigns
yeah it's like politics
this is literal politics right now but
yeah i guess if you stayed that way
do you have like do you have like a
tagline like that it's like yeah jan i
will ask you what you are doing here
i am a chad my name is jan yeah
wait so wait so would you did you have
to do that as well like you would you
have to go to like girls bars and like
stuff like that be like and like oh
a lot dude my the chacho would like just
take all of us the people who build that
night or the people who are like
chilling with other girls that night
yeah yeah you know late into the evening
because um host club finished at like 12
p.m let's say yeah and then we would
have like a you know subsidiary bar
subsidiary
why why is it close to earlier why does
it close to 12
laws bro
you just take you to a different venue
and you know at that bar it's still same
[ __ ] everything is expensive as [ __ ]
yeah but you know you get to just be a
bit more relaxed and then more intimate
let's say
and at that place if you're staying
there for long shacho would come there
and be like yo guys we're going
somewhere and get the boys and go to a
club let's say after
it could be like a bakura or like
whatever
you know establishment you can think of
in tokyo right yeah
and then you know the shacha would pay
for everything i've seen chacho pay up
to like you know six seven k us
one evening for like three four guys
total you know geez he would just shell
the [ __ ] out
but i suppose like considering the
amount of money that hosts making anyway
that's like that's yeah
doesn't care bro he's chilling man he's
chilling so you would do that and you
would go around and interact with the
girls at those establishments yeah
supposedly to basically be like hey when
you come to my club next time
choose me well not when but like you're
coming next week right
it's not a suggestion yeah it's more
like it's a command
right right right oh okay
today so you're coming next week tuesday
right what happens if they don't come
yeah
i mean nothing it's something i'm going
to call the turkish taxes
but if you don't vote for me
i got a lot of taxi drivers
and they're not japanese
that's not what's gonna happen but you
know if you know anything about japan
you know
verbal agreements mean a lot yeah in
japan rather than paper signing most
deals are done through
global agreements that's because is that
true i i i think a lot of things in
japan done by like on paper agreements
from my experience i mean that's also
true but if you look i think socially
speaking yeah socially and traditionally
for example like
a lot of verbal stuff holds more value
to it especially
it's all about the respect like renowned
family if you're from like a renowned
family for example you don't like uphold
your promise
and you know you risk losing that
[ __ ] reputation for your family yeah
your family will [ __ ] like whip you
bro yeah you know but i mean that was
back in the day right now even here now
bro now there's just a lot of big
families
right still to this day like a lot of
people who want to respect their like
you know
yeah yeah i mean not that many anymore
but depending on like the for example if
you look at like really family-owned
businesses
that's how it functions right right like
for example the people who make like you
know
choreography the the calligraphy like
like [ __ ] rare whatever the [ __ ]
hide for whatever the [ __ ]
you really know your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and i saw this [ __ ] pan that was made
out of like
so anyhow um you know imagine you're
like a supplier of this hide for this
pen and then you're dealing with the
people who make like the holding part
the wooden you know yeah you know you
don't make [ __ ] wooden paper
contracts you make robocontracts why
because your relationship date back to
like 150 years right right that's what
i'm talking about but i mean is that the
same as making a verbal agreement at a
goals bar
for you to come to the next now that you
mention it for them to come the next day
right like that i don't think there's
many girls in the kybakura who are like
oh [ __ ] well i better go to this club i
don't want my family on my ass a part of
it does translate though right what i
mean by i'm sure it does but not to the
same capacity not the same capacity not
in the same like respect values but in
terms of like you know if you're if
you're like a you know renowned person
in your bar and you make a promise and
you don't you know protect that or
you know make that come true other
people are going to see you as some
lying bastard right
so you just get outed from the industry
then i guess well not out of but you
know like just bad rooms will spread
yeah yeah you know like
who is she to make promises right right
right right i guess well yeah because
it's such a small industry right
everyone knows each other
yeah exactly you know i was sucking
roland's dick the entire time
but literally you're figuring something
[ __ ]
this doesn't matter bro
maybe
so anyhow um
you know i know a few people who have
you know [ __ ] had fun with him
dragged with him in the past so if i
really really really wanted to i could
still get a message across to him
right i could reach out to his [ __ ]
sns which is saying some dude called
john saying this to him
that's how close contact this entire
industry is doesn't matter if you're
like you know the most renowned host or
sounds like turkish taxi drivers to me
now that you mentioned it bro
[ __ ] do you want to fly at my homies
establish my own network
all the hosts said turkish taxi drivers
honestly like where do people talk yeah
post club how much [ __ ] does john know
all of his clients you know
i'm i'm uh i'm curious about uh
how you know you mentioned your club and
you've mentioned those other famous ones
yes sir is there so first of all how
long have clubs been around two at host
club sorry uh in japan and two what's
the difference between like the older
ones and the new ones
how long have they been around that's
your first question right yeah like as a
subculture yeah thousands of years bro
thousands of years no doubt dozens of
thousands i was like a while no like
[ __ ] oh wow a while horse club culture
has been around for a while but
when it started popping off i would say
in like the last 15 years
right that's when it started it seems
like a really new thing
from the surface to a certain degree
well i think japan has become more
lonely over
technology and when is there like birth
rate when did their birth rate start
declining right about 10 15 years ago
that makes sense
that makes sense that makes sense so
what's the difference then between like
a club that's been around 50 years you
know how do they do business what's the
difference between that and like how you
know say a club that popped up like two
weeks ago uh-huh well i was saying for
example a club like prachino that hosted
you know one of the most legendary hosts
of all time
like rorando
just by hosting them there they can up
their name rather meaning
people who don't know anything about
clubs
they get the club's name into their ear
through social you know right
anything goes on like twitter news
[ __ ] ryan news anything they kind of
see that exposure club i mean it says a
lot that
yeah i didn't know it's awful it's the
most it's horrible fortune to get those
too you know yeah i can imagine the car
with your face on it just yeah yeah yeah
no all i hear sometimes are just like
the [ __ ] word like the political
people were just shouting
speakers you can't even hear what
they're saying they're just being loud
yeah they're so annoying
there's also the one that goes around in
like shinjuku all the time that's like
yeah
i i can't imagine being the truck driver
man you're like how long has it been i
have i have actually seen like when one
of the vanilla truck drive trucks went
past i was like i want to get a look of
this like the actual driver's face yeah
yo he looked brain dead
he was literally it's gonna be that name
from uh caroline the guy on the pc like
that's why you locked it yeah yeah so i
go ahead about the difference between
the clock yeah so so what what would you
say like is it like a difference in
service or like the the way that they do
it or like
the rules
i'll say the main difference is
cut
what
oh
so dramatic so dramatic i need